And in South Korea a zoo is already celebrating the upcoming Year of the Rabbit.
Let's see how they're doing it.
Visitors at this South Korean zoo were greeted by rabbits in traditional Korean costumes...
...in an early New Year's treat.
The fluffy bunnies, Flemish Giant rabbits, and two Rex rabbits, were a hit with the children.
I used to raise a rabbit, but it was small and not exciting enough.
But this rabbit is really big and fun to play with.
Next year is the Year of the Rabbit on the Chinese zodiac calendar.
Rabbits have been symbolizing fortune and richness since old times.
So, the Everland zoo is exhibiting rabbits and has prepared various events.
Come look at these and get a good fortune.
According to the Chinese lunar calendar, the New Year begins on February 3rd.